[Music]
Mandy Moore just saying only hope from
her iconic movie a walk to remember and
it was everything Mandy and her husband
Taylor goldsmith blessed us with a
concert on Instagram live on Sunday
we're figuring out what we're gonna sink
in like an hour so come and join us here
on this couch for some songs the
tracklist was fired and took us back to
the two thousand Sylvie
[Music]
the new rendition was so perfect it's
hard to believe it's almost been 20
years right now
you're straddling the state line okay
you're in two places at once
[Music]
a walk to remember was based on the
Nicholas Sparks novel Mandy played Jamie
Sullivan a teen who was diagnosed with
leukemia
I was getting along with everything fine
I accepted it and then you happen
Jamie falls in love with bad boy landing
Carter played by Shane West shedding
more of a positive light on the typical
high school experience which is
something that I think I'm even more
proud to be a part of the song only hope
comes into play when Jamie performs for
Landon during a school play
and we can't forget about that surprise
kiss at the end
Jamie Landon forever et talked to Mandy
Moore back in 2018 she revealed that the
movie was a pivotal moment in her career
my first lead role in a film and a walk
to remember like that really just
changed the game for me and it like it
kind of solidified that I wanted to be a
performer and that I could do it even
though I had no idea what I was doing at
the time and that yeah it like kind of
got the ball rolling and the ball has
been rolling ever since Mandy has
absolutely crushed it as an actress with
big movie roles and in 2019 she earned
her first Emmy nomination for her work
on this is us but we gotta admit we'll
always have a soft spot in our hearts
for Mandy the musician
[Music]
[Music]